being cast on Game of Thrones can be a
mixed blessing
on one hand acting in HBO's hottest
series concei riously booster acting
resume on the other hand given the
show's history you're probably going to
get killed off sooner or later of this
long list of casualties kind of test
here's a look at some of the major
characters who have died on the show and
were the actors who played them are
today Harry Lloyd Viserys Targaryen he
was supposed to be the true king of
Westeros but Viserys Targaryen was the
first major character to meet his maker
on Game of Thrones when coal Drogo
crowned him with molten gold during
season one actor Harry Lloyd has kept
himself busy since dying on Game of
Thrones continuing to acts on television
and in movies like the theory of
everything his next project is a
starring role in the 2018 Starz sci-fi
thriller series counterpart mark addy
Robert Baratheon after a hunting trip
gone wrong in season 1 King Robert
Baratheon first of his name died
fronting his best friend Ned Stark to
take action against the machinations of
Cersei and Joffrey since leaving Thrones
Starmark idea surfaced on several
television series including great
expectations and the syndicate more
recently had he appeared in the 2016
miniseries Jerrica and as a detective in
the 2016 crime drama series new blood
Sean Bean Ned Stark after Robert's death
Ned Stark tried to take control sending
a letter to Robert's brother Stannis
inviting him to come take his rightful
place on the throne
unfortunately for Ned Cersei was two
steps ahead of him and the ned famously
lost his head on the executioner's block
at the end of season 1 you know which is
a very you know he sacrificed himself
for his family when she was a very
moving a very touching moment and and in
a good way to go really although Ben has
a reputation for being killed off in
many of his projects he hasn't let that
stop his acting career since Thrones has
appeared in a variety of projects
including the Martian and the legends
and the some of his other recent work
includes roles in the six-part BBC
miniseries broken and the 2017 thriller
film drone Jason Momoa Khal Drogo
although Cole Drogo was dead essentially
from the moment the old evil witch lady
infected his wound with her fake
medicine his actual death was much more
tragic as Daenerys had
Kait him with a pillow to put him out of
his misery at the end of season 1 Jason
Momoa 'he's brief Game of Thrones
10-year served him well in Hollywood
leading to win the role of Aquaman in
the DC extended universe films Batman vs
Superman Justice League and 2018 Aquaman
solo adventure and mob OA seems like
he's enjoying the ride
get then Anthony renly baratheon
following King Robert's death his
younger brother Renly attempted to claim
the throne Renly had one of the largest
armies in the southern kingdoms and was
beloved by everyone everyone except his
brother Stannis however who used black
magic to murder Renly in season 2 asked
the game of Thrones
actor Gatton Anthony appeared in a 2014
film Copenhagen as well as the popular
series called the Midwife then
demonstrated his range by playing Joel
Munson and the NBC period crime drama
Aquarius he also provided the voice of
Gil Brody in the video game Mass Effect
Andromeda Oona Chaplin Talisa maegyr
standing in for the book character of
Jeyne Westerling Talisa maegyr married
Robb Stark the king in the north
unfortunately Robb was already engaged
to the granddaughter of Lord Walder Frey
through exacted his revenge by murdering
Talisa at the red wedding in season 3
after Game of Thrones Oona Chaplin
starred in the 2014 miniseries the
Crimson field and an episode of the
popular television show Black Mirror as
well as a 2015 movie the longest ride
some of her latest projects include
starring roles in the 2017 spanish
comedy film as we like it and the
British drama series taboo Richard
Madden Robb Stark the king in the north
Robb Stark Bettis and beside his beloved
Talisa taking a knife for the heart from
the traitorous Roose Bolton it was a
traumatic way for actor Richard Madden
to end his time on the show and managed
to get on the plane it covered in fake
blood I was kind of upset at the end of
the whole job and I kind of looked I
think I look like I've murdered someone
thank God just like following his exit
from Game of Thrones in 2014 Madden
appeared in the series Medici masters of
Florence and of the prints from the 2015
live-action Disney adaptation of
Cinderella Madden can be seen in the
2017 Amazon original series Oasis
Michelle Fairley Catelyn Stark though
Catelyn dedicated her life to protecting
her children she died at the red wedding
believing she had failed them all since
her terrible death in season 3 actress
Michelle Fairley have stayed busy with
projects including the television series
resurrection and the movie in the heart
of the sea as well as the stars
miniseries the white princess Jack
Gleeson a Joffrey Baratheon
thankfully the reign of psychopathic boy
King Joffrey Baratheon came to an early
end
Joffrey married the widowed Margaery
Tyrell but his reputation of an evil
jerk preceded him so what grandmother
protected her by slipping from
fast-action poison into his cup of the
reception Jackie Gleason retired from
screen acting after Game of Thrones but
he remains involved in the arts he
founded collapsing Horse Theatre Company
in Ireland which won an award for their
perfect show peasants face at the 2016
first Irish theatre festival in New York
City thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love team
[Music]